[Music]
what the is this piece of hey
everybody Michael nolles here you're
hulking Adonis and cultural Maven I've
been asked to examine the curse the
plague of fat phobia take it away people
on this app don't like to talk about it
or at least lots of people don't like to
talk about it but we're going to talk
about it today okay if you're scared of
being fat you're fat phobic it's in the
definition I'm sorry to tell you just
kidding I'm not sorry put a
pause there so it's not in the
definition right the definition of a
phobia is an irrational fear why are you
afraid of fat people why don't you like
it honestly ask yourself this question
but she just said if you're afraid of
fat I don't know anyone who's afraid of
fat people but that wouldn't be the
definite you might be reasonably afraid
of a fat person like a really big fat
sumo wrestler who could maybe just fall
down on top of you and Crush all the air
out of of
you that would be a rational fear that
you I wouldn't there'd be nothing phobic
or irrational about it keep going the
first like 20 years of my life my
biggest fing fear was gaining weight I
spent so many years of my life freaking
out over you know gaining weight or not
fitting in the same pair of pants or
whatever and anytime I would try and
work out to be healthy it was always
always always always always because I
wanted to lose weight weight loss
culture Ed culture diet culture all of
it is rooted in fat phobia because our
country is rooted in fat phobia yeah
back when she used to go to the gym and
watch what she ate and work out and
everything that was back she was doing
that to lose weight but now that she
doesn't want to lose weight and she is
now an anti fat phobia activist look how
happy she is doesn't she seem well
adjusted isn't she thriving and living
her best life thank thank goodness she
gave up on that I love too she says
America is rooted in fat phobia I think
I can smell like it's not rooted in
truth justice in the American way it's
not rooted in Liberty equality no
specifically fat phobia yes I can
definitely smell sh that's the root of
our country according to these Scholars
and activists right now go to
genucell.com letter y letter T our
friends at genus cell have launched a
new product called genus cell 3 which
works fast on your under eye bags and
puffiness JL 3 is smoother more
luxurious and it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration it is like Gatorade
for your skin this new genus cell
technology keeps your skin looking young
and healthy for years to come the genus
cell fall Classics package also includes
a jawline treatment for a more firm neck
and jawline it also includes Genia
cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer and
deep Firming Serum get your skin ready
for the cold and dry weather if you
don't look and feel your absolute best
you will get your money back no
questions asked go to genucell.com nsyt
or you can call 800 skin skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package results in 12 hours or less the
immedia effects are included for free by
the way the founder of this company
great Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left there for the American dream so
head on over to Jus cell.com letter y
letter T or call 800 skin SK i n 211
next one should we be worried about his
health problems now this guy this guy is
definitely someone whose BMI scale needs
obese should we worry about his health
is he going to have a heart attack I'm
sure if lost some weight they would be
much healthier be much better at the
sports they compete in and have much
happier lives don't you agree fatness is
not inherently unhealthy also fat people
don't owe you health two things okay
shut up so first she points to people
who are extremely muscular and she says
see these people are large just like fat
people are large but they're not large
in the same way because muscle and fat
are different oh
my I can't it then she says look uh fat
people aren't unhealthy which is just a
non-seer she doesn't provide any
evidence for that and then she says and
also fat people don't owe you health
well okay you just gave away the game
it's like when people say the the border
wall is cruel and evil and inhumane and
walls don't work well hold on if it's
cruel and evil and inhumane it sounds
like it probably works it sounds like
they stop the people from coming over
and make it harder to but if it doesn't
work then how it cruel and evil and
inhumane it's not you're just you're
you're making two contradictory
arguments or arguments that at least
subtly undermine one another because you
know that neither argument on its own
really stands up to scrutiny keep going
also weight stigma against fat people in
medicine hurts thin people too even in
my comments section there were people
people telling stories about how they've
been neglected for diabetes testing
because they weren't fat enough to have
diabetes the first time I was told I was
obese was by the we fit when I was
[Music]
14 and I did not have a healthy
relationship with my body until I was at
least 24 the world's biggest killer is
anorexia think about why that is I don't
think the world's big killer is anorexia
how dare
you you have stolen my dreams in my
childhood with your empty words and yet
I'm one of the lucky
ones I think it's probably heart disease
and I anorexia is a really horrible
thing obviously but I think it's
probably pretty low on the list I think
it's pretty far way down so I'm going to
think about that if you do not date fat
people because you just happen to view
fatness as neutral but not be
particularly attracted to it fine that's
a preference if you don't date fat
people because you think being fat means
that they are gross lazy live an
unhealthy lifestyle or are embarrassing
to be seen with in public that's fat
phobic but to insist your preference is
for people who aren't lazy sloppy and
disgusting and unhealthy meaning that
means you prefer skinny people because
all fat people are those other things
that's actually biged that's actually
deciding that one group is all the same
because of how they look hope that makes
sense have a good day it doesn't quite
make sense I mean I don't pass these
judgments on people when I see them and
there're all sorts of explanations for
how people got to be the way that they
are but let's not take that to such an
extreme that we're now severing the the
line between actions and physical
consequences behavior and habits and
Lifestyles and the way that you look
you'll see it if if if you go out and
abuse drugs for 20 years you're going to
look like Hunter Biden Hunter Biden was
a pretty good-look guy back in the day
and he's not a good-looking guy anymore
cuz he's destroyed his body through
extremely degenerate Behavior if you're
going to the gym every day and you're
going to church and you're eating well
and you're living a wholesome lifestyle
you're probably going to see that
reflected in how your looks change over
time that's there is a a link between
those two things I'll use my own example
I understand I am an Adonis and I
understand that I am a sex symbol both
here in the United States and
internationally but I'm willing to admit
something which is that I do not go to
the gym that's just not something I do
you know I don't think it really matters
and some of us just wake up like this
but if I went to the gym I would have
bigger muscles and you would see those
bigger muscles and somebody walking down
the street would look over at me and say
wow that guy you know he's probably
pretty motivated and he goes to the gym
and he works really hard at that and and
that's admirable and virtuous and I
think that's great Oh What a Beautiful
Day hey how was your workout today did
you crush it if somebody is morbidly
obese they probably have a problem with
gluttony and we all sin and fall short
of the glory of God but that's a problem
and if you want to grow in virtue then
you should probably stop that you know
you should put the cupcake down oh this
cookies I got to get the rest rap from L
put that cookie down now that's true we
can draw those conclusions it's natural
it's reasonable I hope you found that
lesson educational and if you didn't
like it coming from a skinny boy such as
me that would be an example of your
melophobia the fear of skinny boys just
like me see you next time hey are you
wom but don't you come
around unless you weigh around 400 lb
will if you wake up all baby come around
it
all